I just found out I was um pregnant with
a our miracle baby back in on Friday wow
wait a second how why how is this a
miracle baby give us the
story because unfortunately we've had
two miscarriages in the past 13 months
oh and we were actually going to start
doing IVF we'll save up for IVF but we
actually got back into the FPU and we're
like you know what we're going to put
that to the side and let's just tackle
all the debt because we have an
overwhelming amount of debt um mainly
business debt but because everything is
personal collateral I just think it's
all personal debt anyway you would be
correct you're right your name's on it
well congratulations I haven't even told
my husband because I don't even know I
feel like I can't even be excited you
told us before your husband you told you
you told these two clowns and millions
of other people before him I hope he's
in a hole somewhere safely